- Okay, Mike.
Ow!
- So today we're waxing
each other's chests,
because apparently I don't know
what a bad idea is anymore.
- Oh my God!
- We're playing a game,
it's called Wax for Wax.
An expert is going to put
a strip on both of us.
- And he'll rip it off of me,
then I'll rip it off of him.
- I'm slowly starting to realize
that this is a really bad idea.
- I mean, how painful can
waxing really be, right?
- I think the chest is very painful.
It's a very sensitive area.
- Right.
- You may feel like your skin's
coming off as well (laughs).
- How hot is the wax?
- It's not that hot.
- Oh, that's frikken hot!
Oh my God, that's 100 degrees.
Nothing to be afraid of, honey!
- Oooh!
- Argh!
- Ahhh!
- [Mike] I'm so sorry.
Oh my God.
- I did that!
- I feel like I just killed
a small woodland creature.
- Ahh, ahh you did.
- It's like someone
shot me in the shoulder.
People do that on their private parts?
- So, round one was--
- [Mike] Awful.
- I'm running into the office to see if
anyone else wants to play the game.
- [Voiceover] Hey, Jared, do
you want to play Wax for Wax?
- Say what?
- It's so warm!
- [Ned] What are you guys doing?
Oh, it warm, oh-oh.
- I'm glad neither of us are bleeding yet.
- Yet?
- (laughs) I don't want
to do this anymore.
- It's gonna be terrible.
- She seems like she knows
what she's doing, though.
I, on the other hand...
- Argh!
- Ooh, man!
- Ah!
- [Voiceover] One, two, three!
- Argh!
(laughs)
- Ooh, like I got bit by a tiger.
- Is it bleeding?
- I hate that feeling.
- Five, six, seven, eight!
- Ooh!
- Oh-ho-ho!
- God, get some! I need to pump.
- Ooh my God, ow!
- [Ned] Get some, wax that, right here!
Do it again!
- Oh my God, my chest is on fire!
(laughs)
- You were good!
- I don't feel good.
- Well, Zach, I've got a
meeting to run to, so--
- Great.
- [All] One, two, three, (mumbles).
- Ready?
- No.
- Oh my God!
- Urg!
- Aah!
- I'm so sorry, argh!
(laughter)
- Sure, final thoughts.
This was chaos.
- It was weird that at the
same time, like, with each rip
there was a bit of an adrenaline rush.
- I felt alive, that's what it is.
- I felt alive.
- I mean, I regret it.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] I definitely have to do
some kind of maintenance,
'cause this looks awful.
I look like an idiot.
- [Zach] I think I'm just
going to let mine ride.
I'm just going to like, be
like, yeah, this is the style.
- [Dimitri] Yeah, that's your summer look.
- My summer look.
In fact, I'm going to have
to groom to keep this going.
- Oh, I hate this day.